[Musique]
ces prisons devait normalement être la
plus dure d'europe
elle ne devait pas avoir de file un
traître c'est à quelle heure les visites
c'est à quelle heure les visites gardien
comment vont les petits et les grands 18
mai un taux faut montrer tout le monde
qu'on peut encore se battre
une évasion de cette prison tu perds ton
temps on va faire ce que j'ai je sais
pas encore comment mais en est en marche
bien pourri de matton qui les paquets
effet les heures sup pour qu'on reste
ici
il doit sûrement y avoir une faille je
me porte volontaire pour bosser voilà
avec moi on n'arrête pas la grève bovine
c'est un jus d'âge de même la prison
c'est ça mais on s'y habitue au bout de
dix ans regarde la forteresse vous fait
confiance il ya rennes a piqué de toute
façon la confiance que si tu mets les
boues tu pourras pas aller chez toi
jamais
c'est quoi qu'est ce que tu as
pour moi il ya ce que mon équipe à 16h
en a qu'une tentative en russie bouge
pas tu fermes ta gueule
tu sais quelque chose parmi tous les
gardiens de la prison c'est moi que tu
as choisie
[Musique]